I just do my everything from Australia
can kill me I feel like if I was growing
up in Australia I wouldn't make it
snakes sneaking in the house spiders
sneaking in the house terrifying
dangerous creepy yeah dad
yes I'm daddy I'm dad looking at it is
that a horn that he stabbed you with the
eyes have an agenda here all that crap
that's on his beak is like human flesh
it could probably beat you to death
hobby like a heads up kind of thing like
a ram this is gonna [ __ ] kill ya
livin ah this is an animal it seems
pretty colorful and I know for a fact of
the more colorful and animal the more
venomous in us yeah you can see a face
in it and it's like it could probably
destroy your entire life I'm into it but
it's definitely gonna kill you it's
definitely poisonous and I think it can
kill you
ooh yes like spiders can kill all
spiders can kill you I'm not gonna lie
my butthole clench when I saw that
spider doesn't look like an innocent
spider it maybe will dig a hole in my
face
and plant its babies I feel like it's
not actually a poisonous spider it's
just like a very big ass spider I mean I
would know it looks pretty harmless
enough
here the tiny angry mouth there's
something kind of charming about this
snake
it's like friendly house stink hey how
you like it would hurt but I don't think
it would I want it wasn't I don't think
it will come yet I don't know I like the
looks of this guy I feel like he would
kill me though if you had the chance
oh my god I don't kill me I don't trust
him I really honestly don't trust him at
all like I wouldn't want to run into
this guy in a dark alley just imagine if
one of these guys killed you that would
suck you'd be like what the [ __ ] how
would this then kill you maybe it likes
strangle to its tiny penis if you like
if you run into nice one maybe it won't
kill you if my death comes from this
adorable face creature then so the end
one way to go I accept I still really
want to go to Australia definitely not
going in the water ever like I walk on
the beach I'll check out the cute
peoples I'm probably not going to go
parading around the outback this is good
training because now we know like okay
which ones to look out for which ones
are cool you gotta respect those murder
animals yeah that's all they're asking
for just a little respect just a little
thanks a lot for the nightmares strong